за ці роки я мабуть не бачив настільки
стільки жорстокості
скільки було в Маріуполі коли я знімав Я
плакав коли я монтував Я плакав коли я
дивився цей фільм
кінотеатр
смерть дітей це найстрашніше мені я як
батьку
для мене це було найстрашніше
впевненість багатьох росіян тому що це
вторгнення чимось оправте
і тоді вони подивляться цей фільм ваш
фільм 20 днів по Маріуполі отримав приз
глядацьких симпатій на головному
американському фестивалі незалежного
кіно сантес перш за все Дозвольте мені
ще раз привітати вас з цією нагородою і
скажіть будь ласка що вона для вас
означає
Дякую це велика нагорода і вся команда
дуже щаслива особливо тому що це
призвід глядачів це
значить що фільм
прийняли прийняла публіка прийняв глядач
це значить що люди не відвернулися від
трагедії це значить що
широкий публіці не все одно що
відбувається з Україною те що ми взяли
цей приз значить що фільм побачив широка
аудиторія це те що нас важливо Це
значить що
мільйони людей будуть в смузі побачити
правду
відео журналіста агентства США і тут
прес і з першого дня російського
вторгнення в Україну Вита ваш колега
фотограф Євгеній малолетка були в
Маріуполі і документували руйнування
міста і вбивства мирних жителів
російськими військами ваше фото і
відеозйомки публікували провідні ЗМІ
всього світу Скажіть будь ласка як і
коли у вас виникла ідея створити ще
документальний фільм
іде виникла не відразу ми просто кожен
день посилали відео та фото але оскільки
не було зв'язку якщо ви подивитесь фільм
всі знаємо цю історію в Маріуполі не
було зв'язку Маріуполь Маріуполь був
повністю блокований щось
відправити звідти
було Майже неможливо але нам вдавалось
деколи відправляти хвилину дві
найважливіших кадрів але коли ми
вирвались уточнення це було на 20 день
тому що він називається 20 днів
Маріуполі
у мене було близько 30 годин відео а
відправив Я може 30-40 хвилин тобто я
розумів що
потрібно зробити більше ми відчували
провину щоб ми поїхали ви відчували що
нам потрібно зробити більше і
тоді виникла ідея зробити фільм тому що
коли є
глядач
коли люди дивляться новини вони бачать
30 секунд чи мабуть хвилину
півтори хвилини це вже великий сюжет
вони є бачать лише шматочки вони бачать
у них немає повної картини але фільм
дає контекст фільм дає можливість
розуміти масштаби руйнування
масштаби страждань через які пройшли
українці і жителі Маріуполя і на
коли я розмовляю з глядачами я я завжди
кажу що от ви бачили 20 днів Але
Поставте це в перспективу
був 21 і 22-й і 30 і 90-ий і зараз вже
майже рік повномасштабного вторгнення 9
років
вторгнення Російської Федерації в
Україну і це теж ви бачили це кожен день
оце відбувається
з Попасною соледаром бахмутом
Тобто це не поки що не
минуле це
те що відбувається саме зараз
як для вас це було емоційно
це
в кожній точці цього шляху
мене переповнюють емоції коли я знімав Я
плакав коли я монтував Я плакав коли я
дивився цей фільм
кінотеатрі я також
тобто емоції завжди залишаються але і це
боляче це завжди боляче
але це те що робить нас людьми і
всі українці травмовані всім українцям
боляче але всі ми тримаємось правильно
тобто
так такими є Що ж робиш
Як ви вирішували які кадри увійдуть до
цього фільму
насправді
те що ми змогли показати фільми це це
тільки може Один відсоток від того що
відбувалося
було знято набагато більше
а відбувалося ще більше і На жаль ми
ніколи не зможемо до кінця зрозуміти
масштабів цих руйнувань можемо
представити собі подивившись фільм ми
можемо собі це представити але
[музика]
до кінця побачити ми цього не зможемо на
жаль тому що Маріуполь повністю
від нього нічого не залишилось і його
ніхто ніколи
може українці може ми коли повернемось
до Маріуполя бо він будуємо його але
зараз це просто місто
просто пусте пусте місце
там нічого немає
і
для нас було дуже важливо не
відштовхнути глядача
тому що
коли
якщо показати все що ми бачили то є
небезпека просто
того що люди відвернуться від екрану і
не будуть дивитися Тобто нам потрібно
було знайти баланс між
тим щоб показати Правду чи показати всі
страждання і не відштовхнути глядача
Мені здається що нам це вдалось
доказ тому приз глядацьких симпатій але
Мені б хотілося показати більше
А що для вас було найстрашнішим за ці 20
днів вашого перебування в Маріуполі
смерті дітей це найстрашніше мені як
батьку
для мене це було найстрашніше
в цей час я думаю про своїх
доньок
І ще одне мабуть найстрашніше це
відчуття що мені не можемо нічого
змінити скільки ми не знімали скільки ми
не показували це світу все одно це
продовжувалось
це було страшне відчуття що ми нічого не
можемо зробити і я думаю що в багатьох
кого ми бачимо що він теж є таке
відчуття а в лікарів
які не змогли врятувати дітей
у військових які
змогли втримати цю навалу
Скажіть будь ласка А як сталося так що
ви та Євген малолетка залишилися єдиними
міжнародними журналістами в Маріуполі
це гарне питання Я думаю що це
феномен просто тому що місто
400 тисяч людей в світі де всюди камери
де всюди є журналісти
тільки два
фотограф оператор продюсер ще була
Василь Степаненко продюсер і був ще один
документаліст з Литви який якого На жаль
вбили росіян
як це сталося Я не знаю в якийсь день
коли вже було зрозуміло що Маріуполь
оточують що вже
минуча і закривалася всі шляхи виїзду
більше журналістів всі журналісти
міжнародні виїхали вони поїхали до Києва
по-перше тому що в Києві відбувалося
нам всім тоді здавалось що там
відбувається головний біль за країну
і так було в той час і всі міжнародні
журналісти ти поїхала але Ми настільки
прив'язані
серцем до Маріуполя Євген народився в
Бердянську біля Маріуполя Я з Харкова
але ми багато знімали в Маріуполі я
трошки жив Маріуполь Тобто
це важливе місто для нас і ми розуміли
наскільки Маріуполь важливий для
стратегічно для Росії тому що вони ж
хотіли пробити коридор в Крим собі
І ми вирішили залишитись
але так це це незвично і
на жаль це дуже погано тому що
є приклад коли ми виїхали і на наступний
день після того як ми виїхали росіяни
розбомбили драмтеатр в центрі Маріуполя
і в місті вже не залишилось нікого
зовсім нікого і
ніхто не знав скільки людей загиблих
ніхто не міг зрозуміти спочатку Що саме
сталося
Що там все що сталося з людьми які
вижили у нас пішов десь місяць на те щоб
просто реконструювати
поговорити зі свідками реконструювати
всі події
зрозуміти скільки могли людей
скільки було людей вбито Тобто це ще раз
підкреслює наскільки Важливо щоб в зоні
бойових дій щоб в місці де
потенційно
можуть бути скоєні військові злочині
наскільки це важливо щоб були журналісти
щоб це документувати
це ще одна мотивація чому ми залишились
ви працювали військовим кореспондентом в
раку в Сирії в Афганістані після того як
ви виїхали з Маріуполя ви продовжуєте
документувати війну в Україні чим на ваш
погляд відрізняється ця війна від інших
збройних конфліктів
Я знімаю конфлікти вже 9 років все для
мене це почалось почалось з України і я
не вибирав цей шлях Він вибрав мене і
багатьох інших українських журналістів
які просто було журналістами почалась
війна почалась російське вторгнення ми
всі автоматично стали військові
журналістами
і за ці роки я мабуть не бачив настільки
стільки жорстокості скільки було в
Маріуполі але
це теж пов'язано з тим що це дуже
близько до серця це моя країна Я все це
відчуваю
з'явилося з'явилося відчуття що всі
конфлікти в світі пов'язані якщо
подивитися на конфлікт в Лівії
нагорному карасі Всюди є Росія
все це пов'язано
так чи інакше
але
емоційно для мене Україна неважливіше
звичайно і найболючіше
люди страждають всюди однаково
чи мають побачити ваш фільм російських
глядачі і чи є шанс що він може змінити
позицію тих хто досі вірить що не все
так однозначно ще раз ще раз скажу що
мабуть в цей
в тих інформаційних реаліях в яких Ми
зараз живемо
[музика]
вже
в інформаційному просторі бій де не за
те щоб показати комусь щось показати А
за те як люди будуть інтерпретувати
ті чи інші кадри Я сподіваюсь Я
сподіваюсь що
цей фільм побачать не тільки росіяни але
весь світ
і я сподіваюсь що якщо не зараз то це
станеться може за рік за два за три
тобто будемо мед коли
впевненість багатьох росіян тому що це
вторгнення чимось оправте
похіднеться і тоді вони подивляться цей
фільм і тоді вони зможуть інтерпретувати
ці кадри отак як воно було насправді
тому що якщо зараз вони його подивляться
то це нічого не дасть тобто
ті самі народи які були вони і
залишаться це все Fake News це це
неправда Це все актори
Я вже зараз бачу реакції
на публікацію те що
фільм переміг називається Я вже зараз
бачу реакції на російській в російських
телеграм каналах що
зновус знову постановка і так далі І так
далі тобто повинен прийти час але він
буде там він буде там чекати цей ще він
буде чекати тих людей які захочуть знати
правильно
що ви плануєте робити далі я повертаюсь
на передову і продовжую знімати
продовжуй свою роботу
продовжує знімати новини якщо знайду
тему для нового документального фільму Я
буду знімати новий документ але поки що
моя основна робота це посилати це кожен
день знімати
те що відбувається на передовій те що
відбувається в українських містах
і
[музика]
показати те як українці
не відступають про те як українці
попри все
не віддають свою землю